Let's start by thinking about how we'll put tiles together after we compute them.
Each individual tile will compute partial results for these P destination threads.
The partial results will reflect the contributions of the forces produced by these P objects,
then, for each of these tiles, we'll add the partial results from all the tiles in a row
to get the complete set of forces that act on the P threads in this band right here.
So let's say we run this tile with P squared threads.
That's going to allow us to compute all P squared individual forces at the same time.
This is good, very parallel, but it's got a couple of not too major, but still significant, downsides.
First is that we would have to share both source and destination parameters for each object across multiple threads.
Remember, we're only fetching each item once.
How many threads must get the information of parameters for each source object and for each destination object?